one two three this helium balloon could
hold the solution to a big problem today
4.5 billion people are without internet
access Google is betting on the moon
project to solve that a floating hotspot
powered by solar panels able to tell
flowed for three months pretty much
anywhere for health google turned to
fancy space agency an expert in
stratospheric balloons for 50 years it's
significantly cheaper than satellites
but it is for areas with less people's
and satellite satellite sebring a global
coverage on all the planet balloons are
for a local coverage balloon system was
tested in a remote farm in New Zealand
with success hey guys yes faster very
good but Google isn't the only one
tackling the problem facebook wants to
build special drones n on Mars can
Richard Branson many satellites French
tarter be bound has another idea well
our solution it the fastest to deploy
because it works now and is extremely
cheap there is absolutely no
infrastructure investment required be
bound has created an app to make better
use of the 2g networks which already
cover eighty-five percent of the planet
it's already partnering with local
operators such as GG in Algeria and has
ambitions of extending to Asia and Latin
America with a low bandwidth you can
have facebook email Twitter geo
localized services search the web you
can have eighty or ninety percent of
what are you doing but not videos
connecting the planet is a big task that
requires a mix of solutions and known is
perfect the Google values for example
will need to be retrieved after losing
air
but if the solution is viable thousands
of these could circulate the earth in
just a few years